you remember how in The Wolf of Wall
Street movie Jordan belr would train all
those guys to make a bunch of money with
them dialing the phone well think back
who were those guys were they
sophisticated educated smart Harvard
grads no they were actual mindless
degenerous that Jordan Belford found off
the
street minus the generates who were
willing to just follow a script good
pick up the phone and start dialing and
here's the thing is that this movie was
not an exaggeration in fact this is how
it usually is in real life just take a
listen to what the former president of
the real Wolf of Wall Street had to say
about it but when I was working for
Jordan the cool thing is that we got a
chance to fly around the country all
throughout the year we went from company
to company and Industry to Industry we
got to really see you know who are these
top uh performers who who are these
people making millions of dollars
whether they're the business owners
themselves or whether they're
salespeople or any other individuals who
really make a lot of money and the crazy
thing that I found is that all the
wealthiest people were the most mindless
people and the trick though is that they
were mindless in the right way and part
of it is cool anyone really can get rich
but I bet that a part of you was really
annoyed by these types and you should be
annoyed they're not smart they're not
educated I'm clearly smarter than them
so why are they making so much more
money than me well the reason why they
make more money than you the reason why
you're not a millionaire might actually
be because you're just too smart no
seriously it turns out that the average
college GPA of the average American
millionaire is just a 2.9 GPA hey you
know anyone who's not from the United
States 2.9 more or less means that you
didn't completely fail out of school but
you were very close to it which means
that most of rich people out there
they're not Geniuses they're not
intellectuals they're actually just
incredibly average on the intellectual
scale while the people who did go to a
good school who did get a fancy degree
who Pride themselves in their education
nine times out of 10 they always hit a
plateau that's definitely something that
I've seen in real life it's very rare to
find someone who did really well in
school actually make millions and
millions of dollars consistently each
year usually the people who did well in
school tend to be stuck making six
figures the rest of their life I was
super academically tracked my whole life
and I graduated from UCLA around the age
of 19 with a degree in math after going
through that I even went to law school
and I got into other you know ivy league
masters programs in science and
technology but I went through all of
this just to realize that this is all
kind of a big scam and a big lie this is
arva Ali by the way on top of being the
former president of the real wolf of w
stre company Jordan Belford he's also
the adviser that celebrities
Millionaires and the ultra wealthy go to
when they want to grow their net worth
he spent a ton of time with the people
who actually made it into the 1% so he
knows what they're actually like behind
closed doors he's got his own YouTube
channel that will link below you should
definitely subscribe if you like what he
says in this video and I wanted to ask
him why why is it that quote unquote
dumb people end up making more money
than quote unquote smart people and
we're going to expose it all in this
[Music]
video let's get something out of the way
first that I know a lot of you are
thinking but Jake what about the tech
billionaires and the finance
billionaires out there they're not done
they're Geniuses I can never be as smart
as them well in actuality most of the
billionaires you see are not Geniuses
they're just really great at playing the
character of a genius what you'll always
find is it's only the tech billionaires
and the finance billionaires that
aggressively try to portray themselves
as Geniuses nobody else really does why
would they go through such lengths to
pretend to be a genius simple it's
because their entire business model
relies on convincing you to invest your
money with them to invest in their
startup to invest in their investment
fund and the only way they're going to
get people to invest is if the masses
believe that they're a genius after all
I am a genius so your money is much
better off in my hands than yours the
perfect example of this is Elizabeth
Holmes of Theos before she was exposed
everyone thought she was a genius but
when it all came crashing down everyone
realized that she was no genius now she
was just obsessed with looking like a
genius she was copying all the quirks of
Steve Jobs all in an effort to get
people to invest into Theos it was the
same story with Sam bakman freed
everyone thought he was this Ecentric
genius but as it turns out he was also a
complet complet dum dum same thing with
the Wei work guy same thing with the
weor guys lead investor masay Yoshi son
and the same thing with so many other
Geniuses of yester year and yet for some
reason we still want to believe in these
types it's not like a situation where
you find you know people sitting in some
room you know planning and strategizing
and being some genius no one's sitting
there trying to be some genius and it
never works out and it's nice especially
I think for guys we want to fantasize
that we can just sit there and be a
genius and make a lot of money but the
real world does not reward that in any
way it best rewards the person who
actually cares to be a value to more
people so the next time you see some
billionaire trying to Market themselves
as this allseeing genius you and I would
know that it's all a charade but that
still begs the question why are most
wealthy people quote unquote dumb
[Music]
then Barbara corkin was called the dumb
kid all through high school she was a
straight D student who couldn't read or
WR thanks to her dys leesia at 23 years
old she borrowed $11,000 from her
boyfriend to start a real estate
business and today she's worth more than
$100 million Mark Kean only got through
his college technology course because he
cheated on his exams and instead of
going to some ivy league business school
he picked Indiana University without
ever seeing the campus just because it
was the cheapest option available after
college he was fired or quit three
straight jobs before finding something
he was good at ironically it turned out
to be Tech the same subject he had to
cheat in order to pass and today Mark
Keepin is worth more than $6 billion
Barbara and Mark are two of the most
well-known investors on Shark Tank and
if you look at the other sharks
backgrounds you will find the same story
almost all of them were average or
pretty bad in school and of those that
actually made it to College most ended
up in some average school and they
majored in something completely
unrelated to business as kids Society
branded them as failures they were the
ones that were all called dumb at some
point in their lives and yet these
people with their 2.9 GPA make up the
vast majority of the ultra wealthy why
if you look at the people who can keep
building and growing their business for
the long term not just for some you know
3 month stint where they thought of
something crazy and you know it might
work out initially people who really
build a business for the long term are
simply the people who are who allow
themselves to turn off their brains and
most importantly turn off their ego and
let their pride you know step to the
side for a second and are willing to do
the the the unsexy process of knocking
on doors of the unsexy process of making
phone calls doing cold emails um uh
being of of genuine service to people
and not trying to figure out a scheme
it's really about like how many people
can you actually be of service to and
even if like for example if you have a
restaurant you know you can get really
busy with one restaurant and have some
number of customers but the person who
makes a lot of money is just the guy or
girl who decides to keep opening up more
restaurants and goes through that
process of improving herself or or
improving himself to actually be able to
keep servicing more and more customers
and that's the really really simple
answer to it is it it does not require
some genius plan and some genus sort of
scheme for example let's say you were
one of these kids that Society branded
as dumb and you decide to start your own
business you create your products and
now you have to go knocking door to door
to try to sell it and right from the
start you get a lot of negative
reactions people ignoring you slamming
the door in your face that kind of thing
but since you're mindless in the right
way since you don't have an ego and or
like I'm too smart for this you just
keep knocking you just keep picking up
the phone maybe it takes 100 or even 200
Doors maybe it takes 100 or even 200
phone calls but just by the sheer law of
numbers eventually someone is going to
buy and once you get that first sale
then you just keep mindlessly repeating
that and improving it and then that one
sale turns a two then 100 then 10,000
since you had no ego you probably asked
for help and found the right teacher
along the way and with that right
teacher you just kept mindlessly
listening to them you didn't try to
reinvent the wheel so those 10,000 sales
eventually turn into a million sales and
then boom one day you wake up and you
find yourself among the 1% of society
not because you were smart but because
you were mindless in the right way now
let's compare this to someone educated
someone Smart in society's traditional
sense why can't they do
[Music]
this
let's say you take a straight A student
that graduated from a top university
they started business and now it's time
for them to go door door trying to sell
it well this guy has probably spent his
entire life hearing how smart he is how
people expect great things out of him
and due to his 4 to8 years of
conditioning I mean education in
University he's been taught that as long
as he follows the rules he will get
rewarded as long as he memorizes the
thing and fills in the correct bubble he
will pass so what do you think is going
to happen the moment that he knocks on a
door and gets rejected do you think he's
just going to mindlessly continue no I
did the thing and it didn't work when I
do the thing I'm taught in school it
always works so this is a sham I quit
and so he quits he quits doing the one
thing that would have guaranteed him
making a lot of money and it's not his
fault that he's like this it's the
education system's fault yeah I mean the
most important thing is school does not
reward you for actually giving value to
anybody you see what I'm saying so it
has no correlation to making money the
the only thing that determines how much
money you make is how much value you can
provide to other people's lives either
either through the products you create
or through the services you provide and
at what point did you ever do that in
school everything that you learned in
school is nonsense in my opinion like
once you get very sort of advanced level
with with anything related to math or
science you start to quickly realize
that everything that was taught was
distilled in such a way where it can't
possibly even make that much sense uh
for the average person but it's more so
testing your ability to uh memorize
things in a certain way memorize
techniques in a certain way and show
that you are a good um uh uh you know
sort of worker in the Factory as they
say and that that is you know as most
people know now like that is what school
was designed to do especially during the
Industrial Revolution it was just simply
designed to um create good Factory
workers at the end of the day so uh
there's nothing about uh School uh that
in any way correlates to your ability to
make money because again you're not
actually adding any real value to people
there might be a counterargument to this
which is oh you know School teaches you
skills and knowledge so then you can
provide value to people that's almost
you know almost never the case like even
if you go through K through2 even if you
go through undergrad and even if you go
through med school and law school
there's very little that you learn in
any of these environments that you
actually apply into the real world and
anyone who's an very very advanced level
lawyer or advanced level doctor they'll
tell you this you know privately is that
everything that they learned even in med
school or in law school it almost never
applied to the real world so it's only
through your actual experience and
directly helping people and getting
better at helping people that you can
actually make a lot of money so where do
most of these smart people end up well
most of the time they end up chasing
respectable positions that will make
their parents proud that will boost
their ego but were they're just a cog in
the wheel following orders just like
school things like Finance or Consulting
sure I have to slave away 10 hours a day
until I retire sure it will take me
decades to climb the corporate ladder
and eventually I'll make more than six
figures but hey I'm a consultant for
McKenzie I'm an analyst for Goldman
Sachs on Wall Street all I have to do is
run on the treadmill and I'll get a
modest carrot just like school count me
in and to be clear there's nothing wrong
with this if you're okay making this
trade but the price you pay for this is
being stuck at six figures and until
you're old and
[Music]
feeble yeah and and a very obvious way
to visualize this is like imagine
imagine you were um uh trying to get
really fit and you want to start working
out the best thing you could do is
definitely go to an actual expert you
know in in uh uh in the type of Fitness
that you're into and have that expert
give you all the strategies and the
plans and everything that you need to do
but then you just go do it you know it
doesn't require a bunch of thinking like
that's that's how sort of Life Works is
is um you can go to an expert get the
right answers and then you just do the
actual steps that you need to do to
mirror you know what that expert uh is
showing that you can get to in terms of
end results so um if you can just find
that expert first that's the tricky part
for most people and most Industries is
just finding the right expert that they
can trust and usually most experts that
especially online um that present
themselves as experts not any in any way
a real expert what they're really doing
is giving you information that makes you
feel like like they're a genius and that
you need to trust them because they're
some genius and that more importantly
you need to become a genius yourself in
order to make money so those those tend
to be most of the people uh that speak
publicly in in the business space and
that's why you know when you follow most
of these people you don't really get
good results because they're trying to
imply that business itself is a
complicated process and hence you know
the reason you're failing is because you
don't realize how complicated it is and
you need to keep navigating this
complicated process with them you never
really get any genuine results the
people who actually provide Real Results
um are are simply the experts who show
that it's a simple step-by-step process
and it's not that you need to be some
sort of Genius a lot of people including
myself always looked up to people like
you know Elon Musk and Peter teal and
Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos all these
random different individuals who present
themselves as as some genius and the
nice thing that they do is they make you
feel like really good about yourself
like oh I I I really like this person
he's a genius now I I can keep being uh
I can keep keep going down this path of
wanting to be a genius and somehow make
a lot of money I've never found that
these people actually gave me real value
in real life where I suddenly made a lot
of money because I followed in their
footsteps the only people where you can
you know follow in their footsteps and
and make a lot of money are the people
who actually have businesses or have a
way of doing business that you can
directly you know imitate and we say all
this coming from personal experience
because both me and arvit fell into the
same trap for Arvid he was on the
academic extreme he graduated from UCLA
with a degree in math at think age of 19
then he went to study law and became one
of the top performing law students there
until one day he realized that he could
make a lot more money not being a lawyer
and just doing his own thing which
eventually led him to becoming the
president of Jordan Belford's companies
where he eventually learned some of the
stuff he talked about today I also fell
into the same trap growing up with
immigrant parents I was always the one
that got good grades that prided myself
in being academically smart but when
you're academically smart or in other
words when you're well conditioned to
follow orders well you're only going to
have one possible outcome you get a safe
job and you Capt your potential for life
just like School intended you to so
that's what I did I got a safe job that
was respectable that my immigrant
parents were proud of but that safe job
also guaranteed that I would never be
able to make more than low six figures
maybe I would eventually make $150,000 a
year maybe 200k if I'm lucky but
anything higher than that would have
literally been impossible 0% probability
it was only after that I got sick of
that job that I finally decided to put
aside my ego to stop worrying about what
my parents thought and I found that one
thing that I could just mindlessly
repeat that was when everything changed
for me and the this was all because I
learned how to be mindless in the right
way and I say all this not to brag but
to show you that if you're not society's
definition of smart consider yourself
lucky because you do not want to be or
if you have fallen into this trap as
well well just like me and Orvin it's
never too late to opt out of the
[Music]
system